we started Life by 28 years in Omar
today they came in their hundreds
old and young with the same clear
message no going back
Wednesday's attack has rocked this
community
old fears have resurfaced those who shot
John Caldwell on Wednesday
where in serious danger of lighting a
fire that could burn us all
it's been 25 years since a car bomb in
Omar killed 29 people including a woman
heavily pregnant with twins the shooting
of John Caldwell just a few miles from
that same spot for many feels personal
it's the people who are out on the
street today the people of oma and the
people across this country who have an
opportunity to stand up and say no we're
not going back to violence we're not
going back to what it was we want to
move forward and we want to move forward
together
what you get from being here is a sense
of the genuine shock and also the fear
about what happened on Wednesday night
police say they're now treating the
attack on detective Chief Inspector John
Caldwell as a terrorist incident and
they say their main line of inquiry is
looking at dissident Republican groups
police say their focus is on the group
the new IRA and security concerns are
high police closed a road due to a
suspicious item today found near the
football club where John Caldwell was a
volunteer youth coach a club that turned
out today to support him there's a
community on both sides are behind them
and it was a Despicable attack that
happened and we never want to go back to
the way things were located we weren't
through that we weren't through the our
mothers and fellows we've been through
but we don't want to ever go back to
John Caldwell a father police officer a
coach remains in a critical condition
his injuries described as life-changing
Catherine hepatoti Sky News Omar